à droite toute c'est comme ça que
listrot amené sa campagne les baisses
d'impôts promises ont su charmer la base
du Parti conservateur mais ont aussi
exposé une candidate qui semblait sourde
à la crise de l'inflation et l'énergie
qui frappe la Grande-Bretagne victoire
en poche elle promet l'audace pour
maintenir ses engagements
on lui a reproché de vagues promesses
pendant la campagne mais il était
injuste d'attendre plus de détails sur
ce qu'elle comptait faire dispartisans
il lui fait confiance
les gens lui demandaient de fournir des
réponses comme si elle était premier
ministre avant même qu'elle poste 10
député
il ne faisait pas de doute que
l'histoire c'est le emporter sur son
adversaire Richy sounac le peu d'écart
entre les deux candidats lui étonne
l'ancien ministre des Finances
démissionnaires du gouvernement de Boris
Johnson avait l'appui d'une majorité
importante au sein des députés du
cabinet ministériel il faut maintenant
les rallier avec des mesures d'aide plus
généreuses pour faire face à la crise
on n'aura pas de deuxième chance pour
bien faire 10 députés qui soutenait
Richie sunnak il n'y a pas que les
députés et les ministres conservateurs
que les strass doit maintenant
convaincre selon un sondage publié
récemment par yoga 52% des Britanniques
croient qu'elle fera une très mauvaise
première ministre
il n'y aura pas de lune du miel entre
l'espace et les Britanniques elle doit
faire ses preuves maintenant
d'énergie lui demande un Gémeaux parce
que beaucoup de gens doivent choisir
entre se nourrir ou se chauffer
pour encore beaucoup de Britanniques qui
vont regretter Boris Johnson l'histoire
qui est resté proche de lui et
rassurante pas
je crois qu'elle soutenait Boris alors
je pense qu'il n'y aura pas beaucoup de
changements mais ce sera intéressant de
voir ce qu'elle fait d'ici on a qui
pardonne tous ses écarts à Boris Johnson
et les prêtres à donner sa chance à
l'histoire tout comme les dirigeants
européens avec qui les relations depuis
le brexit ont été tendus je dis
bienvenue à listrot je lui exprime
toutes les félicitations de la France et
nous sommes à disposition pour pouvoir
travailler entre
comme on dirait allier et amis
tout ça à partir de demain Boris Johnson
et lis Strauss vont se rendre à Balmoral
en Écosse pour rencontrer la reine trop
affaiblie pour quitter sa résidence
estivale lui remettra sa démission elle
sera chargée de former le prochain
gouvernement ici Marie-Ève Bédard
Radio-Canada Londres